every age has its own surveillance
technologies its own ways of peering
into the gloom times change though and
techniques need updating these radio
dishes were taken down in the 1980s and
left to rust in a Lincolnshire field
these are their successes nowadays most
communication is online there is a vast
amount of information and it's collected
and analyzed at stations like this in
GCHQ Butte and Cornwall surveillance
laws haven't kept up with technology
the Home Secretary has introduced the
investigatory powers bill or if you
prefer the snoopers Charter to bring a
mess of existing surveillance powers
into one comprehensive piece of
legislation today we are setting out a
modern legal framework which brings
together current powers in a clear and
comprehensible way a new bill that
provides some of the strongest
protections and safeguards anywhere in
the Democratic world and an approach
that sets new standards for openness
transparency and oversight this new
legislation will underpin the work of
law enforcement and the security and
intelligence agencies for years to come
it is their license to operate with the
direct democratic approval of parliament
to protect our national security and the
public safety the government has also
added one major new Park the requirement
for every person's internet browsing
history to be recorded for a year other
controversial points included who should
sign off surveillance words judges or
politicians the powers of GCHQ and the
question of encryption but the central
dilemma is this how much power should
security services and police forces have
to look at our most private
communications if in the future we have
a situation where the security services
are able to stop terrorist attacks in
the UK and that's a good thing
no one no one wants to be followed
around no one wants to have their
communications intercepted but this is
actually about stopping serious
criminals indiscriminate mass
surveillance is a real concern it's a
violation of people's right to privacy
it has massive repercussions for other
rights of associate
and of assembly and this new bill has
the potential of continuing mass
indiscriminate surveillance practically
every form of communication in British
history has been subject to surveillance
from letters to the Internet Mary Queen
of Scots was executed after a coded
letter she sent detailing a plot to
assassinate Queen Elizabeth the first
was intercepted and decoded The
Telegraph when it was invented quickly
became subject to surveillance by the
British government
when telephones were invented they were
tapped all of these intrusive powers
required a warrant in the late 19th
century people were listening through
walls with glasses stuck to the walls
and often in hotel rooms you had a
double suite so a spy could hire the
room next with a flimsy wall in between
and by the first world war they had
dictaphones which they could stick
behind curtains and record conversations
by the 1950s you had rooms huge big
rooms full of computers during the
encryption and decryption surveillance
is here to stay that's for sure we've
lost our privacy it will never return so
what we do need to do is to ensure that
it doesn't get out of hand originally
these four huge dishes were mounted on
high facing out east over the sea
looking for a known enemy using known
tactics and known technologies but today
the reality is a lot Messier and that's
the reality the bill addresses we don't
listen to conversations and if you could
hear the snatches that we do you would
understand why the problem isn't so much
that legislation is slower but that
technology is moving much faster it took
the telephone 75 years to reach 50
million users it took the internet for
years
and the Internet we had pre-2000 was
pretty basic
hello google.com now there are 1 billion
smartphones in the world
Facebook has 1.5 billion users that
incessant online activity is a potential
goldmine for intelligence services but
it's also a danger today's young adults
have grown up in the digital age and
they spend more of their lives online we
are 3 what they thought of the new bill
be on our phones 24/7 I'm on my whatsapp
I'm on my Twitter so it's a situation
where it's like I do not want to have my
information out there especially
conversations private conversations
where these laws are going to have
access to that I don't think that's I
don't think that's right this is
essentially a blanket surveillance
operation there is no sort of target in
this per se it's everyone's data and
everyone's metadata regardless of who
they are and whether they lived a
perfectly innocent life for the past 4
years you need to have a relationship
where liberty and security are able to
be compatible and this takes takes away
liberty and make security the Big
Brother in a sense people's messages
have been divided into two types for the
purposes of the security services
there's communications data and there's
content if I send a text message the
authorities can see what time I send
that message where I was and that I sent
it to you that's done through
communications data also known as
metadata and doesn't require a warrant
but the content of that message what I
write to you can't be accessed without a
warrant the same goes for accessing
websites and opening apps on our phone
authorities will be able to tell which
sites I've looked at which apps I've
used all without a warrant they can't
tell what I wrote in that message though
whether that's a text an email or a
Facebook message to teach them a lesson
that will never forget security services
and police say that communications data
has been vital in foiling terror plots
such as the 2006
and to bring down transatlantic
airliners with liquid bombs I guarantee
that surveillance has been used in all
the prevention of all the the six
attacks I think the Home Secretary in
the head of the security services are
said I guarantee that using technical
surveillance will have been involved in
those that there's no detail obviously
but of course we have to face the fact
that the world is moved on and we need
to have laws that allow the security
services to to protect us it's also
useful in serious domestic crime ninety
five percent of all criminal
prosecutions rely on communications data
that figure includes the prosecution of
Ian Watkins the former lost prophet
singer found guilty of sexually abusing
babies there was no physical evidence
nor witnesses at the start of the
investigation communications data gave
the lead the prosecution eventually
relied heavily on phone contacts and
text messages the other argument is that
the distinction between communications
data and content doesn't make much sense
in a truly digital age given how often
we use our smartphones and how much
information they record the who where
and when can be just as revealing as the
what in a way that a letter or a phone
call just isn't we live our lives online
your browsing history is a record of
your life and under the new laws that
record is open to police and security
services is an additional kind of
intrusion I suppose into into people's
private lives and one that Parliament
needs to think very carefully about in
terms of a whether it's really necessary
and then secondly whether it's
proportionate but it's really the job of
Parliament to come to that determination
Edward Snowden first revealed the scale
of internet monitoring post security
services in 2013 his leaked documents
set in trained a number of independent
reviews of UK surveillance which the
investigatory powers built drawers on
this is where that monitoring happens
and the donut GC excuse headquarters in
Cheltenham billions of data points are
analyzed each day GCHQ s ability to
collect bulk intelligence is governed by
a warrant under the new bill the warrant
must be focused on people outside the UK
however the whole point of bulk
interception is that it devours the
records of millions of people without
regard for their nationality UK citizens
data will still be scooped up one thing
is sure there is no doubt that state
surveillance has exceeded its power
several times the fact that it's being
confirmed that our communications were
intercepted they were held they were
stored and that's a matter of huge
concern the bigger concern is that we
have absolutely no idea what was stored
what was intercepted by the government
what did they do with it
who did they send it to and are they
still doing it the question of warrants
is also key to the new bill in another
respect
previously when mi6 or any of the other
services wanted to access the content of
the communication they'd ask for a
warrant and that was signed off by the
home or foreign secretaries in
Parliament under the new plans though
those warrants will now also have to be
signed off at the Royal Courts of
Justice by a judge the Home Secretary
described it as a double lock system the
judges have a role to play but that role
should be to verify and to check what
has been done and by ministers and it is
absolutely essential that if judges are
to be involved they should be trained
and given a full understanding of the
national security issues they're dealing
with because that is actually not the
natural territory of judges even with a
warrant though there's another problem
with getting at the content of a message
remember how it took the internet for
years to reach 50 million people well it
took whatsapp and Instagram less than
two years these services have superseded
text messages and emails and they're
tricky for the UK government to access
first US companies like Facebook and
Apple are not subject to UK law and they
work with the UK government on a
voluntary basis second some of those
companies keep messages encrypted to
keep them safe so that even they are
unable to unscramble them
a spate of hacks most notably TalkTalk
has only highlighted the need to protect
people online the UK government already
had the legal power to ask companies to
hand over so-called content in the clear
unencrypted communications that power
has never been tested but it has been
retained in the bill even though the
Home Secretary said the bill does not
ban encryption Sky News understands that
technology companies would fight this
power if it were used this bill isn't
just about bringing laws up-to-date with
modern technology for decades police and
security services have worked shrouded
in secrecy but paradoxically as the
threat has become more unpredictable
more unnerving security services and
police admit they have to be more open
about how they work this bill needs to
live a transparency accountability and
oversight
some will frame this as an old-fashioned
two-sided debate security versus liberty
but with so many valid and competing
claims it's much less clear and much
more complex than that
Tom Cheshire Sky News